good morning believe nation today's
message is be yourself over to you kneel
the grassy Tyson I've had several people
come up to me and said what can I do to
be you and the only aspect of me that's
really doable is I can tell you what my
academic pedigree is and what I did as a
kid and what things interested me but
what I do day to day is not the
fulfillment of some pre-existing job
description it's just things that I took
interest in on my own that the general
public happened to also appreciate or
like or want access to and so within my
job description as director of the
Hayden Planetarium and as an educator as
an astrophysicist
I kept accreting other things that I did
that people responded to positively
responded to so I can tell you about the
academic pedigree the rest you have to
create what it is that you do best that
layers onto the formal training that may
be behind it I think the greatest of
people that have ever been in society
they were never versions of someone else
they were themselves you don't think
about Michael Jordan the basketball
player and say oh he was just like this
other player no you don't even say he
was like this player plus that player
divided by 2 plus citizen no he's
Michael Jordan I think the greatest of
people in society carved niches that
represented the unique expression of
their combinations of talents and if
everyone had the luxury of expressing
the unique combinations of talents in
this world our society would be
transformed
overnight I love this message and it's
one of the things that I try to
incorporate on my channel as much as
possible the name of my channels model
in the masters I loved modeling success
and the idea behind modeling success is
not for you to try to be Steve Jobs or
Bill Gates or Oprah Winfrey or Martha
Stewart or whoever the people are neil
degrasse he write whoever we profile on
the channel it's not to be like that
person it's to take pieces of all these
different people to become
the-best-version-of-yourself to think
bigger to stretch your comfort zone
right and so I think the more you can
surround yourself with ideas and people
and resources in an environment that
makes you have the confidence to be
yourself to think bigger to believe in
those big ideas then the more likely you
are gonna be yourself and I think a
tangent to that is thinking about well
how do i how do I find what I'm
passionate how do I find myself and I
think the easiest way to do that if you
don't know I think a lot of us a lot of
people don't know a lot of people just
wander through life because their
parents put them on this path or society
put them on this path or you know they
started out at some job and then just
stuck with it and not now is their
career path without ever giving it real
actual thought as to of us for them or
not a lot of people are lost the way to
find what you're passionate about is to
explore and to say yes to things and try
things and see if it makes you come
alive right until you find something
that makes you come alive if you don't
want to settle and that's what most
people do they settle you settle for
something that's good it pays the bills
it's okay but it doesn't really get you
excited that's why you stop searching
for something great because good is the
enemy of great and so you want to keep
searching till you find the thing that
makes you come alive I was having a
discussion with a friend someone who
interviewed me recently on her Channel
and she's making 2016 the year of doing
things that make her feel uncomfortable
and she's exploring and and most of the
things you know may not be a good fit
for her long term but she's not afraid
to try to say yes and if you get that
feeling in your stomach that I'm nervous
and if I should do this it's outside my
comfort zone right then you start coming
with excuses as to why you can't do it
right - all these stories that come from
your your path
in history is why you can't accomplish
this thing try to stop it right there
and say you know what I'm gonna try and
if you do that enough then you'll find a
thing that makes you come alive and if
you surround yourself with with great
thinkers and great people around you
even if it's just from videos right you
don't have to have great friends or
people who have done great things just
watching the videos and being surrounded
by them that's what I do with my channel
if you discover who you are and then
create that great environment it allows
you to be yourself and accomplish great
things so the question of the day today
is how are you staying true to yourself
and what are some of the forces or
restrictions that are holding you where
you are instead of letting you break
free leaving the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press